this week we've got shoe food great
timing and Pizza flight all right for
our first story the Prime Minister of
Israel had the Prime Minister of Japan
and their wives they all had dinner
together and this whole chef served the
desert in a shoe was it a new shoe it
was a metal shoe so it is supposed to be
an insult my [ __ ] you chip everyone is
saying like what the hell like that
support I bet you he's all like this is
funny is this shoe edible oh wow
no it's like a sculpture like a metal
sculpture oh what's the star beyond the
shoe like why I think it's great I've
got it's probably offensive because you
know just shoes indoors is disk all
because in Japan you're not even
supposed to put your shoe on the carpet
if you put it on the table that's like
[ __ ] yeah but it's a met it's like a
design like people are [ __ ] trip and
they act they're acting like they went
like all I'm gonna have an idea maybe
there are the dishes maybe they're
having a discharge
I know why they just have a couple of
extra metal shoes let's just go to the
metal shoe cabinet pull those guys out
but the dishwasher must be just furious
I bet he's like now I got to do laundry
how do you even wash that shoe - you got
to get in there like a tooth brushing
[ __ ] it's not fair yeah was the of the
inspiration like what was his like cuz
every chef has like some weird type of
[ __ ] that they you know no yeah I mean
all of it is like the Israel's foreign
ministry they're just saying that the
chef is just very creative but they
respect and appreciate him but then
after that first statement they added
later we have the utmost he's also
tripping so we [ __ ] up no they ended
up adding we have the utmost respect for
the Japanese Prime Minister and that was
it like they didn't even explain why
there was a shoe but everyone that's
involved in there just like that
welcome to Israel eat my foot [ __ ] yeah
saying it's insensitive because I don't
know like I'm kind of Japanese in
Japanese the kind of I'm kind of do
these wow I think a lot of people are
offended the only kind of Japanese or
not I'm like wow I don't I don't even
see the so the diplomats there were
pissed well yeah they were saying that
it was very insensitive I get it
I can see why 90% of the world will take
the fit I get to fits us formal
gathering right everybody like under
like this type of behavior yeah and then
you get something served what's supposed
to be like on the bottom of you're like
it makes it weird even it was like on a
like a neon pink plate that's no [ __ ]
way when I look at this what do you call
it like the [ __ ] what do you call
that that that that's special food [ __ ]
that five cores 10 cores yeah yeah like
Oh buffet is it fine if I mess that
course meal
yeah like well we're [ __ ] peasant so
you know what it's called it's called
dinner you freaking I expect I expect
the [ __ ] I expect them to [ __ ] do
weird [ __ ] like I want them to like
bring out a [ __ ] mini toilet bowl
with the sauce ha ha ha way to Japanese
people know just we talked about being
in prison no no like fine plastic bag
and some water had to float to the top
rebid finds anywhere we're eating
[ __ ] foam I agree what I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this I get what you're
saying like yes but in such a formal
public setting - that's [ __ ] weird
but you know what I'll put it to you
know we went to Japan right I was pretty
upset because my food came out wrong Wow
[ __ ] sushi what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
see the vessel upset yeah you know to be
his perspective because you know some
people wouldn't would be kind of
offended if they came out and they had
like raw fish in front if they didn't
know what sushi was they were saying
like if you're cooking a diplomatic meal
you should at least inquire about the
guy
yeah I'm not letting ya I'm not think if
you're like wife has to eat out of a
shoe and fun like it it's like say
you're with your spouse or something I
think you guys both get surf shoes
dinner not only do I now after watching
a wife eat out of a shoe because Israel
thinks it's lerp and ramen like bad
Israel yeah my wife's sitting there
beating the bottom of a food catch a
couple of scallions I'm out of this yeah
it's like kind of weird to so Trump
visited recently and they did they gave
them a shoe so this chef he's a
celebrity shots tacos and they did like
a double faith is that Trump and yeah
it's the Prime Minister's fire this
guy's obviously what playing on the job
all right well is that chess pieces
really edible inside jokes for sure like
him and the Prime Minister has I think
like if I came out and there's like a
shadow of a long dick it's like all
right man yeah but that's like what's up
well I'm sure it'll probably serve a
shadow next like like it's nothing it's
just like I was something in the
distance with a light shadow on your
plate try eating that sounds out of his
brain bro this guys fired dude I used to
work at a Denny's man in this guy they
wouldn't hire this guy they wouldn't
hire him dude you can't do that kind of
stuff make the food you cook yeah
putting stuff in a shoe and sending it
out there this guy's on drugs that thing
cop right are you the celebrity chef -
yeah sure he is yeah but celebrities do
a lot of drugs - yeah they do a lot of
drugs this is just a guy who probably
used to work at a DSW shoes and now he's
picked up a kick a cookbook yeah
and now he's just making it all work for
himself on Instagram wait so we're just
sound like haters that we used to be
congratulating this guy yeah that's true
actually way to go dude you gain the
system dude yeah you're like a school
that [ __ ] you're like a kid it's just
home after school and yeah after you I'm
gonna see like a documentary on this guy
now he goes I used to work at DSW but
now I cook food them together passion
work you know I want to see the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] they'll never know he's the
Russian that lives in his I'll be honest
with you I never met anybody for his
real so that's the closest thing I can
do
oh man you just have to drive anywhere
in Los Angeles Neil sealed yeah you got
to go to Hollywood yeah yeah Israeli got
a good Hollywood man make your dream
come true are you from Israel I'm
Mexican you [ __ ]
my name is Israel Xu foods I wonder what
I would eat out of a shoe nothing well
desert is not a gets it that's like a
gateway drug to eating other food out of
shoes you know like you start with
dessert then next you like alright I
might have a little you know I might
have a little bit of lamb out of a boot
you know what I don't know like Japanese
people have to say anything about the
ship because I remember in Japan they
serve food in like a toilet and then
like the food was made out of poop oh
yeah they had a whole like a poop cafe
so what the [ __ ] are they talking about
alright for our next story there was
this 13 year old boy that he suffered
severe brain injury and his parents
signed off the rights to his like his
organs and then right after they signed
the papers he came back and he regained
consciousness
buddy decide I want the body parts that
we have now obviously they didn't remove
the organs well I do you read to me like
right when they put the beep like no
scalpel over his face I don't think so
so now he has to like at a certain point
like in a couple of months he's to turn
these organs over to people one at a
time it would be the worst like how are
you today today I'm good but tomorrow I
got to drop my lungs off and Reena those
[ __ ] parents can never Yelp that
child ever again you didn't do your
homework you weren't gonna sell my
organs [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] they were
giving them away do they even sell them
how do we go for free
five kids it matched him yeah that would
need it like each one of the organs
already had a kid then are we seeing
this kid selfish yeah cuz since he
survived those five are gonna die now it
was crazy because he was dead a total of
15 minutes hmm that's it they depends
gave up on him yeah you gotta wait at
least 20 minutes your kids your friend
erta anyone his dad 20 minutes is my
role my friends dead after 20 we can
take crazy pictures of the body and
stuff then sell the organs yeah and then
the organ I never count down to three
yeah New Year's I used to have a bucking
elephant like that
no no he's like dog and his mom is ro
he's hella mad now he's smoking crack
with his new lungs that his young
trusted she's for sure accident he
tripped oh he was behind on one of these
things I flipped over and he landed on
his head on that young boys do a lot of
fun things
Lia chef maybe his dad's a chef and he
was serving him in there where the worst
is that Israel there's a lot there's the
yeah I get the house in Alabama yeah
there could be a small house dude yeah
that's wild like imagine you got all
these organs now but you got all these
other kids what about the other kids
what happened to them they needed organs
all right I just went back on the with
woody got all these or he's had these
organs these working together yeah but
not according to those kids they're not
they were counting on ovarian yeah how's
my liver ho like I wonder if you get
like crazy people like cuz then their
families are all pissed yeah kids
waiting for a heart I know and age
they're like we found a donor oh really
oh no he just dude that's just yeah he
won't gonna be so funny as I do my kid
likes it but [ __ ] this other kid
survived so how do you like Bella's
story but dude if you if five other
people could live and you're gonna live
instead bro that's greedy bro it is
that's greedy bro
you should commit to the contract that
was sucking there's a little small town
in Alabama if you're just giving him a
[ __ ] all day is like yeah thanks for
living yeah what are you doing alive I
thought you were dead boy yeah you're
gonna drink that [ __ ] liquor that
live reporter went to that mojito at the
Harbor
oh you're eating ice cream out of a shoe
frickin Muppet I think the real question
to ask him though is how's the afterlife
like also he he actually did mention
that so he says that he remembers
walking in an open field walking
straight he says there's no other
explanation but God there's no other way
even doctors said it well how come he
gets to go to heaven what the [ __ ] he
seems like a piece of [ __ ] to me I think
that's the walkway to heaven he
literally envisioned a gladiator you
know in Russell Crowe oh yeah his hands
against like the Prairie field yeah and
then he was dying to see his family yeah
that's the exact same [ __ ] literally I
know what heaven looks like now just
gotta watch gravity how the one these
people died none of them ever go to help
it's not a trip to Vegas when we stopped
at Barstow what the [ __ ] you're supposed
to just be there but I could see he'll
be like making you think it's nice on
the way there you know there's people
like juggling and stuff and then you get
a little closer and some people at
somebody else catch you they're juggling
babies heads yeah but you don't notice
the first you just think it's somebody
juggle and you look a little closer oh
he's crazy man I don't know if I want to
be a lot of fun you five other people
were like you know sitting there
sweating do you want me to [ __ ] you up
right now oh my god
ah what did y'all have for breakfast
blood what have you done let me rephrase
it do you want me to mess you up right
now like mess me up down what's hate I
don't think that would happen
dang do you want me to stump your
statement
oh forget it I don't know if I should be
erect or not right now forget it moving
alright but yeah look if I do die though
you can give my organs there's five
people that need them in Alabama I have
a small organs bro I got a small the
doctor seven I was born that I had the
ribcage of a large cat yeah
wait how true is that 100% true as much
true as it can be iPod [ __ ] doctors
don't give comments acting like that our
doctors are cool as hell dude Louisiana
oh yeah we only have like 11 doctors
state your son's pretty ugly you learned
from the beginning but yeah I had like
the ribcage of a large cats all my
organs are like kind of nice organs you
know I want to be your doctor dude I
know like this kid just comes he goes
that one right brain of a small baby you
leave him here how we do need some
organs dude yeah for lunch all right for
our last story
JetBlue has announced that they are
flying pizza to California from New York
Wow yeah that's before I could get a New
York Pizza oh yeah hmm Los Angelenos
could give you a pizza from May 9th to
me
eleven that's creme but it's not gonna
be fresh though oh they didn't mention
Pizza Pizza fascist mother day no but
you know how they do it out there right
is they just have it out on display and
they just warm it up that's true but I
still like it fresh though like when
they warm it up ah
oh yeah would you rather have reheated
pizza from New York hell yeah fresh
pizza from here sweet pizza from New
York what the [ __ ] yeah that's one guy
and look at you you don't agree I mean
it's good but it just tastes like I mean
it always just tastes like I'm really
hungry and I'm just having a have it do
you know like I think any I mean any
pizzas almost pretty good really that's
true it's hard to find a bad pizza yeah
it's hard of fun and that's a thing even
7-eleven pizzas bomb oh wow I mean it's
something you'll deal with while you're
you know he's actually not one of my top
who's that what I eat pizza at all
it's not your top eating booty with your
food damn no how did you get so large
yeah bro you ever go hamburgers he did
it on healthy food I know you like the
baby my dad does Lily is a raster bro he
said I do it that great I do that great
at all I'm losing weight and my body's
fighting back
you look what the [ __ ] are you doing it
same row y'all was reading up on this
like psoriasis [ __ ] right so it's
supposed to happen when your body like
attacks like you're healthy cells or
some [ __ ] and it cause like these rays
parts are out on you so I'm thinking
what it is is that me being fat and
unhealthy it balanced it out even and
now that become healthier there's too
many enemies they didn't know which
exactly you're starting to reject
yourself bro no dude your skin's gonna
start eating you alive
bro that's awesome I'm so buff I
coughing up blood I you eat one brownie
they start to go away that's what I
thought too boy Jesus yes uh Spike Lee's
involved with the promotion of his
JetBlue thing that they're calling hi
guy at least he has a job Spike Lee
hasn't done anything in 30 years and
everybody acts like he's so great
because he wears funny sunglasses
promotion oh yeah Pizza Pizza break for
ya baby
118 Street and First Avenue what Patty's
pizzeria
I need translations for this guy no
expression was he a part of the Russian
mob sure thank you Frank you're welcome
none of our boyfriends even eat pizza
first of all don't walk at night do
whole and a half I never ate it like
that it's a good pizza right there new
your pieces you have there so floppy let
him hold the knife
that's a good pizza dad the pizza pie
you never liked oh he has a subtitle do
cereal bread or don't that's a good
piece right
so JetBlue doing so bad they turn into a
pizza delivery where can we get the
JetBlue pizza at so if you're gonna
JetBlue pizza and if you enter your zip
code you can see if you even qualify for
them to deliver straight to your door
oh my god yeah I checked all of our zip
codes we don't [ __ ] you always find
hilarious about these videos they'll
always have like some like European
foreign guy and there's never any
translations but they'll be like one
japanese guy goes hi my name is Richard
it cracks me the [ __ ] up like I don't
what the [ __ ] that guy said but there
was no translation but I am richer I own
this company on the back [ __ ] is this
cheese up in Seattle yeah that's why the
delivery of pizza man I want some but
would you let somebody beat you with hot
pizzas you think no like keep it open
and like just smacked with that yeah I'm
glad you got to eat it after oh yeah a
fresh one or no one hits me in the falls
on the ground first one can give you
like second-degree burns
I know if it's hot yeah it's hot people
it's gonna be so hard where do I sign up
if he's so good after I don't I mean I
out we could do it I don't know what's
your favorite piece of near LAX I guess
I didn't have a pizza I like black
olives dude and no offense I like you
know if anybody's a black olive like if
anyone hates Black Hawk hamburger yeah
hamburger meat you know or other meat
what do you guys eat on pizza I like a
margarita with a sausage on it really
yeah pepperoni
I'm bass I thought you eat something
sorry dude I don't have any clue of
Vietnamese people you know cats and dogs
I mean I've been to Vietnam one time but
I remember we ate you know did you get
like that diarrhea [ __ ] no I just got
regular bowel movements all time I was
there at a blast oh you're lucky dude
but dude you can ask what sites I saw
besides ask him about forget body
when anybody in America like all of us
if we travel to Asia immediately
especially South East especially
Southeast Asia because the bacteria is
different well I must have [ __ ] up
bacteria because I never had diarrhea
out in Asia damn bro Dan you're like
William Wallace you got bacteria locally
[Laughter]
from everything yeah you're like a
make-a-wish adult
Nashville hot - feel like a hot chick
again I love that [ __ ] I woke up today
in in [ __ ] sweats
that's the spiciest ever are you gonna
die you keep experimenting with
different foods I keep trying to eat
like food on white you should stick with
pizza you said you're like he's a GP you
got to take a really good guy yeah I'm
over 20 fancy [ __ ] man just eat rice and
water yeah take it easy
yeah you got a relaxed cause I looked up
like what foods you shouldn't need for
psoriasis and basically said any food
that tastes good yes I'm gonna do
psoriasis yeah you need to take a month
off from eating man you gotta
[Music]